so is it's a pleasure to be here again I
guess I've been to Berkeley many times
but never never to this part of Berkeley
so nice to branch out so yeah so indeed
i'm going to talk about recent work with
ahmed and she who are here and then with
fernando pissed off ski Benny Yoshida
and John Prescott from Caltech
explaining this connections so you know
I won't be able to explain everything
but you know yeah hopefully at least
you'll be able to get the basic idea by
the end of this and then I'm happy to
discuss it more so usually usually when
I give this talk I start with a DSC ft
but I guess given the audience today I
decided to start with quantum error
correction this time so ok so indeed
right quantum error correction is Daniel
explained you know you have some Hilbert
space so I guess Mel so maybe so I'm
just going to put in the tensor
factorization from the beginning I guess
maybe I'll be a little bit less general
so it's a the Hubbard space is a tensor
factorization to end smaller systems and
you know we can just think of them as
qubits well like maybe in a minute they
won't be but for now let's think of them
as qubits so then so okay so actually so
so I defined it i define the code is the
code subspace with the correction
protocol actually at first i didn't put
in the protocol and I thought Daniel
would be mad at me so I put it in but
then he didn't include it so that's fine
so we have some code subspace which I'll
call HC and I'll think of it as being 2
to the K dimensional so we can think
that roughly we have K protected qubits
k logical qubits that were embedding
into n physical qubits so so as daniel
said I'm today only to be interested in
correcting eraser errors so that's where
we tried to recover from the loss of
some known collection which alcohol II I
guess he called it s of the qubits and
now what do I mean by recover well he
wrote it over there but but I'll say it
again so so so so given the code
subspace and then so this I tilde so
tilde here is all
is going to be encoded when I ready to
tilde over something so the I tilde is
just some basis for the code subspace
this is a complete basis for the logical
qubits then what I'm going to mean by
being able to correct for the erasure of
E is that there's a unitary
transformation acting on a bar so e bar
is the set of qubits that weren't erased
the ones we have in our lab and I want
that unitary transformation have the
property that if I act on any one of
these basis States for the code subspace
so you see II Bari here just means that
this is the total you know this is a
state in the Hilbert space of all the
physical qubits then I just get back I
so I get back you know the the you know
the state of the physical qubits of the
logical qubits in this basis on the
first k cubits of a bar and then I get
back to some state of the rest of the
bar and E which which is independent of
I ok so so so so the only difference
between what Daniel said really here is
that because I'm restricting to erase
your errors I can take that I can take
the correction protocol to be unitary it
I don't have to take it to be a general
completely positive trace preserving map
you know it's something you just just
given the system you can put it into
your quantum computer and you can now
I'm an nes oh this is just what I said
so right the dimensionality of e 1 e bar
one here this is just if you like the
first k cubits of e bar just because we
want to we and we're going to want to
put the you know the unencoded message
somewhere so okay now then the reason
why we like that right is because now we
have some some state in the subspace
here this is some protected state and
then you know we can take that and maybe
we lose e it gets flushed down the
toilet or whatever but we can act with
this ue bar on the qubits we do control
and then we just get this state right up
here on you know on the first k cubits
of the bar sitting in our hands so so
this is this is equivalent to so the
existence of this you
is equivalent to the condition that
Daniel gave for the code being correct
correctable now actually here's another
equivalent definition 11 that's better
suited for my purposes although maybe it
seems a little bit more formal at first
so say so say that I have some operator
Oh tilde so again tilde remember means
encoded so so so it's it's it's some
operator that implements a logical
transformation within the code subspace
with these matrix elements but this
hotel de right it's in general just some
could be some complicated operator
acting on all the physical qubits but
but I want it you know it implements
some transformation on the code subspace
and I'll insist also that it's its
hermitian conjugate also implements the
conjugate transformation on the subspace
so it doesn't have any funny
off-diagonal elements so then here so
here's the here's the equivalent
definition so so we can correct for the
erasure of a subset e if and only if for
any till de so for any such a tilde
there always exists an operator OE bar
which acts just on a bar on the qubits
that we do have access to and which
implements this 0 tilde and whose dagger
implements Oh till the dagger so if you
like this is just saying that any any
you know if the code is correctable than
any logical operation on the Hilbert
space on the code subspace can be
implemented just by an operator on e bar
so this is sort of this is related to
this idea that he has no information
about the system sorry said you'll allow
this OE bar to be a function of not only
02 by the function of sight I want to
choose the absolutely not no absolutely
not no in the same way that I don't
allow the the correction procedure to
depend on the state I mean if it did
then it would be nonlinear evolution and
it wouldn't be something we could do
with the quantum computer we have to
learn how to violate quantum mechanics
to do it there are actually people who
like to do that in our field but that
this particular violation but but but
that's not what I'm doing today
okay so yeah sorry this is a little bit
dry but I just I thought I thought it's
good to just get this out there clearly
and it helps that Daniel already
discussed this in his dog doesn't have
any information I hope to say something
like whatever informations because if
somebody comes Paige sorry yeah right
but then it yeah so I guess I was sort
of implicitly using something like the
no cloning theorem in my head so if I
can so so busy what this is roughly
saying is that sort of any observable
you know any any any any observable that
acts within the code subspace I can
measure sort of by measuring an
analogous operator that acts just on e
bar on the part that didn't get erased
yeah and then it's it's a homework
problem to convince yourself that that
this statement is equivalent to the
existence of this okay so okay now i'm
going to give an example because i think
right we've all been sort of formal so
so so here's a very concrete example so
so actually this is where i learned
about this as this actually where it was
invented okay so they got that right so
this is maybe the simplest example of a
quantum error correcting code i just
want to embed a single logical cute writ
so that's a three-state qubit into three
physical cute rates and now the annoying
thing about this model is that three
appears in to logically distinct places
so just you know bear with me there's
there's three physical cute rates and
the code subspace is three dimensional
and principal those are unrelated okay
so so so here's some state I that in the
code subspace and then the idea is that
we pick this subspace this is a subspace
that we pick the reason why we well
there are several reasons why we like
the subspace one is that it's sort of
obviously symmetric between the three
physical cute rates right under under
permutations of the cute race but also
the important thing is Daniel already
explained is that any state in this
subspace is maximally mixed on any one
of the cute rates so any one of the cute
rates has no information about the state
okay now the reason that's nice is
because we can define this you now like
this right so so let's say that's the
third cute that gets erased okay so now
we're going to try and construct Au Au
just on the first two so so you 12 so
okay I claim another homework problem
well actually would be a better homework
problem if I didn't tell you the answer
but I claim that the u12 that acts on
the first two cute Ritz like this indeed
has the property that if I act on any
one of these you know these three states
right then I just right I you know the
zero one or two here on to the first
cute writ and I get this steak I here on
second two and now so if you're actually
doing this you know I send you these
three cute rates in the mail and the
third one gets lost well you don't have
the third one so when you implement the
first two so you implement this you 12
on it and then what you're left with is
some maximally mixed density matrix on a
second one which you can just you know
flush down the toilet or something
because because you've got the state
back on the first one okay so and then
because the subspace is symmetric right
clearly there's also going to be a you
13 and at you two three so we're going
to be able to to recover the state on
any to you using any two of the three
cute rates so that so this is a sort of
the simplest example of the the general
thing that Daniel was talking about and
please ask questions I mean I know this
is kind of a freight train but I'm happy
to be stopped at any point okay now in
the model we can also understand so that
this was the sort of state
recoverability definition of correct
ability but I also gave this other
definition in terms of in terms of
reconstructing the logical operators
just on just on the part that didn't get
erased so we can see that work here too
so so right so say Oh tilde you know is
one of these operators that acts within
the code subspace well I can do this
right so i can further i can define a
new operator 01 to where I first act
with this you one to so that right that
that decodes the message on to the first
two turret now well the message is in
the first two trade I act with this 01
so I act with the onion
encoded version of the operator I just
act with the single cute rate operator
that with those matrix elements and then
I rien code with with you 1 2 dagger and
so the so this is some operator that
acts within the code subspace in however
i like so i can i can put in sort of
arbitrary matrix elements here for how
this guy acts within the code subspace
and i and i can always do this
construction actually this isn't special
to the model i mean this this this was
true in the more general discussion also
this is how this is how you relate these
two notions of correct ability and and
then so as before right because the u13
and the u23 also exists there's also
going to be a 0 1 3 and 0 to 3 okay so
that i can represent these logical
operations or on any two of the cute
rates okay so so so that was that was
all I was going to say about quantum
error correcting code so so if there
were any sort of things that you didn't
get from Daniels talk or if this isn't
clear ask now otherwise it's on to
gravity all right so now let's try and
relate the stadia cft so patrick said
some of these things and his talk this
morning so sorry i'll just say them
again maybe in a slightly different way
so this is this is the metric for
anti-de sitter space if you never seen a
metric before this probably isn't that
illuminating but you know T is some time
coordinate this symbol means coordinates
on a sphere of dimension D minus 1 in
this are some radial direction the
picture is like this right so so anti-de
sitter space is like the world in a tin
can you know so this is our equals 0 in
the center r goes out this way t goes up
this way and then the sphere direction
it's kind of go around and like patrick
said it has the nice property that you
know if you're sitting in the center and
you shoot a laser pointer away from you
it goes out to the boundary and comes
back to you in finite time it's sort of
like quantum gravity in a box if you
like this is sort of the this is the
sort of infinite square well of quantum
gravity
maybe the simple harmonic oscillator is
a better analogy okay now this is this
geometry of course is just empty ad s so
if that was all there was to the world
it would be a very boring theory of
quantum gravity it would have one state
and nothing would happen in it so so to
get an interesting theory we need to
have more states so the idea is we
define these asymptotic ly 80s states
where you know they differ from this
geometry at finite values of this radial
coordinate you know because like that we
put a person there and the geometry was
responding to that but then but then it
large enough are with the the geometry
comes back to this ad s form now it's
very important here that in this setting
that right it is this R goes to infinity
right then so since the geometry just
becomes like this and then at large our
if we look at the the metric that's
induced if the geometry that's induced
on a fixed our slice right then we get
the sphere and we get this time and
they're both x the R squared at large
are so the geometry just becomes a
sphere times a line so there's the
boundaries sphere and there's time okay
so what well so what is that then we
have this great proposal from maldacena
that well quantum gravity in these
asymptotically ad s space x is really
defined non-perturbative lee as a
conformal field theory which is living
on this boundary boundary of the
cylinder or boundary cylinder is depends
your term ok so now well precisely
defined what does that mean exactly well
well here's what it means so there's a
dictionary that relates things in the
two sides so first of all the Hilbert
spaces are equivalent so any state in
the cft and you state whatsoever has a
bulk interpretation you know it has some
interpretation you know as some type of
excitation of anti-de sitter space and
vice versa although the vice versa isn't
so clear since really probably it's
better to think of it as a definition
from the cft to the bulk
the Hamiltonians are the same as or the
other generators of this of the
symmetries so the you know the state's
fall into the same representations you
know the eigen the eigenvalues of the
hamiltonian and the cfd are the
eigenvalues of the hamiltonian and the
bulk theory that it defines but then the
the real so these are sort of formal the
real meat comes from comes from a
relationship between fields in the bulk
and local operators in the conformal
field theory this is the relationship so
you take a field right so feelin the
bulk is going to depend on all three of
these coordinates and then the idea is
we take we extrapolate the field taking
are going to infinity and rescaling by
something this delta is the conformal
dimension of this operator and then and
we get some indeed we get some local
operator so see now it just depends on
time in the sphere so it's on this are
times the sphere that the cft is living
on and this is supposed to be an
operator equation this this equality is
supposed to hold in any state okay so
this is a so all three of these
statements are quantum statements and I
want to emphasize that because you know
often you go to talks about atsc ft and
all they're doing is solving classical
gravity equations so I mean this this is
the quantum statement of the duality
okay now the way that quantum error
correction is going to get involved is
that we're going to try and was there a
question no okay and please again please
stop me if there are questions so right
the way quantum error correction is
going to appear is that we're going to
try and do something which is called
sub-region sub-region duality so that's
something that well several people in
the audience were really some among the
first people to think about there were a
couple papers from berkeley by raphael
bend Stefan Vlad and Claire and then
also a bartek with Mark and then I guess
I actually don't know who these two
people are I don't know who are they
guys matic as I am is a professor at UBC
luck with Mandy's Challenger
another negate I quit physics since then
he was my program thanks student I say
okay good so yes so so so so this was
something maybe for four years ago now
maybe three or four years ago these
people were thinking about the idea said
sort of in a more computer scientists
friendly way is you know say we're given
access to the quantum state of only a
sub region of the cft so remember the
cfd is a quantum field theory on a
sphere so you know the hilbert space is
spanned by you know field configurations
on a sphere it's a tensor product of
different parts of the sphere we give
you the reduced density matrix just of
the quantum state on some part of the
sphere say the North hemisphere or
something and then we ask is there a sub
region of the bulk that we can still
learn about or in other words is there
quantum information about the bulk which
we still have access to even though we
only have part we only have a sub factor
of the Hilbert space of the conformal
field theory so so said this way this is
sort of very obviously an error
correction question right we erased part
of the sphere and we're trying to see if
we could still recover information from
the part that we didn't erase okay now
in fact not only is an error correction
question it's a it's a aircrack
correction question that has an answer
or at least a partial answer which is
which was explained by these people so
strictly in the bulk using using
machinery which is not totally clear
from the cft point of view so by solving
the bulk equations of motion as operator
equations perturbatively in the one over
m expansion which is not a very natural
set of words if i just handed you a spin
system but in the bulk is very natural
you arrive at this sort of remarkable
kind of formula so I Bri we're going to
now have to spend a sec on packing the
picture in the formula so so this this
the cylinder here again is anti-de
sitter space this point x is some point
in the bulk and we're going to be
interested in a bulk field Phi of X
which is located at that point X okay
and so intuitively you can think of this
Phi of X as a logical operator
just for reference now the claim is that
well now I also have to introduce this a
here is going to be a sub region of the
boundary so so this circle so i'm doing
here i'm doing a ds3 so the boundary is
on a single circle x time so a sub
region of a circle well at least if it's
connected it's an interval so this a is
associated with a sub factor of the
hilbert space in the quantum field
theory ok now the according to this sub
factor or the sub region r2 to this
sub-region there's a sort of messy way
of associating a region in the bulk
which i've indicated by this figure I
won't describe it in detail but roughly
you take this a you construct this green
diamond in the boundary which is called
d of a and then you look at sort of the
intersection of the future of d of a in
the past of dfa and that describes this
sort of wedge of cheese here which sort
of lies in between this curve here and
these dashed lines in this green diamond
it's a wedge like a you know which and
now okay the claim is that if X lies in
this wedge this w of a then it has a
representation in the conformal field
theory we're in the conformal field
theory the the support of the
representation so this o is some local
operator I'm integrating this local
operator over this d of a the screen
diamond and only over the green diamond
so so it means that this operator indeed
this logical operator if you like has a
representation just on a ok so so it has
a rip so so in other words if I erased a
bar that wouldn't bother me I could
still implement this logical operator by
acting by acting with this
representation of it
no I'm actually going to carefully not
distinguish between those yeah so so
hold your horses yes wolves some kind of
first little taking the this direction
to a tiny I recommend no that's that's
that that's the wrong way but yes it's
true they like to say those words but
you don't have to say those words you
can say them in a way that I said do any
of you know you just have to understand
that this K is should be interpreted as
a distribution it's not it's not really
a function it's a distribution but
that's fine a distribution is not a
function a function is a special case of
a distribution yeah you have to
integrate it against something it's a
mat it's a it's a it's a linear map from
the space of functions two complex
numbers Delta functions distribution
that's not a function that's right yeah
yes so so for it to be a quantum error
correcting code you need that if you is
like a small area of the cylinder no
matter which ex you take inside you can
always recover it from the compliment
and so we're gonna I'll say I'm gonna
explain a lot more about that in a sec
yeah this is just to give you a sense
that from I mean the point of this is
just that there's some operation which
is fairly natural from the bulk point of
view which looks a lot like this
reconstruction of logical operators to
make the connection precise I'm going to
have to tell you what's the code
subspace and you know what are the you
know what are the what are really the
logical operators and so on which I
which I will in a sec but but this
should already be reminiscent at least
so it's the statement then for a point X
deeper deeper in the fold
are more sensitive to erase your
information erase your on the surface
the opposite you're better and better
protect it yeah i'm going to emphasize
that in a sec though so just just one
say that that's sort of the same as what
he was asking yeah that's right okay so
this is you know this is kind of messy
this is more intuitive from above so so
let's just take this slice here that
this this spatial slice through the bulk
whose boundary is this circle and let's
just look at it from the top okay that's
what Daniel was drawing over here so
then this a is this interval here right
and then and then from this a we can
define this reg region which I'll call
the causal wedge just a name and then
the claim is that this Phi of X where X
is inside of here has it has a
representation in the cft on the region
a but but this Y which over here is
outside of the wedge does not have a
representation in the CFDA that's the
lesson you should remember these are
their operators their local operators
that depend on that point there yeah so
in a quantum field theory they act in
the Hilbert space only on the tensor
factor at that point from that's what
you would say in a quantum field theory
here they're in the bulk so it's not
totally clear that those words make
sense but yes morally that's right yeah
they're operator if you like they're
just operators labeled by a point in the
book okay so so so using this kind of so
this is called the Rindler
representation of the operator so we can
use it using it we can we can you know
we can reproduce so we refuse one
feature of quantum error correction here
here I'll reproduce another so here I
cut the boundary into three pieces a B
and C and now let's look at this guy in
the center here so this guy in the
center it's not in the causal wedge of a
nor the calls a wedge of beam or the
causal wedge of C so it has no
representation just in a B or C but but
it actually it does have a
representation in either a B or B C or
AC okay so this is very reminiscent of
what was happening in the queue trip
model right where where the logical
operators I could represent on one and
two or two and three or 13
but here but here we see it just coming
out of you know solving wave equations
into a corn field theory and curve
space-time so in this case the logical
operators are not all the operators in
the box but only in this region yeah so
in well this is so so if for this K this
is like sort of this is like this simple
very you know the here yeah let's just
say there's only one you know there's
one logical operator in the center or
something yeah i mean the model i'm
going to explain the cycle have more but
but but this is sort of a you know the
same kind of thing we see at least is
happening here has happened in the 3q
trick code okay so now this is relate to
what catherine was asking so indeed we
see that we have this nice feature that
operators near the boundary are less
well protected than operators near the
center so for example this this dot in
the center you know say say i have this
big green erasure here you know well so
what I can just reconstruct it going
around this way right you know or this
big one here while I can just
reconstruct it going around that way so
so it's actually protected against quite
large gracious where's the this one over
here near the boundary well this tiny
little red erasure is already enough to
kill it okay so so if you like the
there's a sort of a nice sort of map
between the sort of radial direction and
the well-protected pneus of the
operators you know and this should be
reminiscent of the you know people like
to say actually an 80s safety there's a
relationship between the radial
direction and sort of scale in the
boundary theory this is a sort of very
precise illustration of that usually
it's sort of a sort of a more of an
emotional statement okay now um oops I
forgot some pauses here okay so yeah so
in the paper with she and Ahmed we
thought a lot about how to say this more
explicitly you know how to really in the
cft tell you what's the code subspace
you know or what are some interesting
set of code subspaces what are the
errors there are some interesting
subtleties some of which involve sort of
generalizing what you mean by occupy out
by a quantum error correction but you
know in the end there's sort of a limit
to how much you can say because you know
it's a strongly coupled cft and
and you just can't compute everything
that you'd be interested in knowing so
so more recently with Fernando Benny and
John so I guess yeah we love our acronym
this is the acronym for the paper we we
were able to come up with a rather
explicit set of codes which are actually
stabilizer codes which is the word I'm
not supposed to use so it's a cat won't
use it again I promise which are
generated by tensor networks which is a
word that I am supposed to use and which
illustrate sort of many of the features
that we sort of sort of more implicitly
decided that you know must be there in a
DSC of T so so so and you know the way
things work in the model is basically
sort of it all works as we thought it
was going to work but it's much easier
to explain because it's discreet and
it's totally precise so actually i'm
just going to explain the discrete model
rather than trying to tell you how to
embed these things into the you know
into the cft is it better for the
computer scientists anyway ok so so the
idea is that it to be that we're going
to replace the model you know we're
gonna replace the cft by just a chain of
em qubits ok n qubits and then you know
I'll indeed i'll consider a 2 to the K
dimensional subspace of states of the
qubits and I'm going to interpret the
subspace as corresponding to the set of
low energy states in the conformal field
theory whereby low energy I mean energy
less than M Squared if we were say if we
were talking about n equals 4 super
yang-mills this big capital m squared or
if we were doing 1 plus 1 dimensions it
would be energy that's low compared to
the central charge
we're to be clear the units are made up
by the radius of the sphere so the
central char in units in charge and
units of the size of this facial spatial
sphere okay so so so I'm going to build
I'm going to build the this subspace by
a tensor network so the tensor network
after I've contracted everything i'll
show you the tensor network a minute but
after I've contracted everything it'll
just be someone big tensor where there
will be n sort of output legs and K
input legs and then I'll interpret that
as defining a subspace in the Hilbert
space of the output legs right so so
this guy on the right here maybe I
should put a tilde here to be consistent
with my previous notation I apologize
the the subspace here this is the wave
function in the physical qubits of the
states in the code subspace and is
defined by this tensor you know the
tensors i'm going to use to build the
network are not just going to be any old
tensors they're going to be very special
tensors now in some sense that's bad
because you know then it makes it sound
like whatever I'm going to say is going
to be very finely tuned on the other
hand I would just say my goal here is to
come up with a simplest possible thing
but you know I'm not going for
generosity here I think many of these
things will still roughly be true if the
tensors are random I think Brian and she
and Ahmed are working on that or
discussing that but I'm just going to
give the case where I choose the tensors
sort of optimally whatever the opposite
of adversarial is friendly yeah so um
what you are so is it what you are doing
here is just like a reformulation of
what we have heard like previously in
the language of of error correcting
codes or is there something to construct
beyond but
be assured well I'm not sure what to say
I mean so the code i'm going to describe
is a stabilizer code so in that sense
it's Daniel invented it you know however
many years ago but it's not the kind of
stabilizer code that people usually
think about so in some sense it's a new
kind of stabilizer code oh my god sorry
no none of it was purely a sociological
comment can I tell you at the end I
promise I'm not going to use it on
civilian defensive may be forgotten no
no no stabilizer codes have a special
powley structure okay fine you have n
qubits there's a group of products of
Polly's acting on all of the qubits you
pick an abelian subgroup which you call
this you pick an abelian subgroup no
they do not all commute X does not
commute with Z so there's the non
abelian group of products of pallies on
all of the qubits you pick some abelian
subgroup just however you want to pick
it and then you so any product of
Polly's its eigenvalues or plus or minus
one you look at the subspace which is
plus one okay and that defines the code
subspace that's a stabilizer code but
the more generally what I said it but
it's just a grassy space of honeymoon
yahoo is committing forget them yeah
particular community but it resided
there are very special kinds of
projectors made out of Polly's yeah
thought the sir that was what i was
trying to emphasize yeah so i was trying
to wrap my head around the this issue of
you have a code some some information
and in those clothes wedges to the
boundary yeah is it cordoba locally
meaning it is it's it's the opposite of
what we think about as Eric white think
oops oh yeah sorry I logical information
is actually the point of your business
that's right so if you want so the code
i'm going to about to describe is not
going to be a good code to make it a
good code you have to make it you have
to turn it into a subsystem code where
you only view a subsystem of the code
subspace as being with a set of things
you care about so but but it'll be more
clear in a minute I
right I mean there's some freedom to you
what you consider logical operators and
what you consider errors so here I'm
going I guess the way I chose to define
the code subspace here is defined to
make high energy physicists i'm happy
i'm sorry happy but unfortunately
therefore it makes computer scientists
I'm happy because it's a bad code so
when we wrote our first paper we defined
the code subspaces so that they would be
good codes and then we had to deal with
all sorts of confusion from from
high-energy physicist who couldn't
understand why we define the codes that
way so here I inverted it's I'm sorry
but it'll be more clear what you see the
model I think ok ok so now so ok I'm
going to build that I want to build this
big ten sir I'm going to build it with
the tensor network and so you know
unlike you know most tense or network
talks I'm going to tell you what the
tensors are the what what the tensors
are going to be sorry Bartek so so i'm
going to pick the tensors to be what are
called perfect tensors so perfect
tensors are is a tensor with 2n indices
and even number of indices but it has
you know each index has the same range
but they have the special sort of almost
magical property that any balanced by
partition meaning any split into end and
n of the embassies gives you a unitary
transformation ok I claim tensors with
this property exist ok what for any n I
think it depends what you do with the
range I think if you're willing to play
yo yeah you would know this yeah I
probably if you're if you're willing to
play with the range maybe I think it
exists for any but but I mean if you
pick the range and end and it doesn't
always work so the so so and I actually
right it's not it's not obvious that
that these exist and they're sort of
intimately related to error correcting
codes if I don't care
I don't need to if I don't worry that
the ranges to fight say I always allow
the range to be high is there a program
that can I input in and it gives me a
coat it debt wish has Daniel that
question so this is this is like whether
or not there are their threshold yeah
yeah so are their threshold are there n
K threshold schemes with any nmk as long
as you allow d to be large okay number
two basically I'm sorry yeah that's
right up to that yes yes okay yes to
read three and Michael yeah that's what
I thought so that's why I said you would
know yeah I silly said we just well it's
not it's to having it's easy right the
dominant so great yeah okay so so so so
let me just give you one example of a
ship ship who are you okay so let me
give you an example of such a tensor so
so the three cute red code that I that I
defined earlier is it actually gives you
an example of such a tensor so here here
I remembered the tilde so so so you just
take the wave function of each of these
code states that i wrote down earlier
and that defines a for index object and
i claim that this this object has this
property and it's that it actually it
follows from from so it basically that
it follows from the fact that this knew
existed and that that there's what
Daniel mentioned that on any on any one
of the cute Ritz it was maximally mixed
not just independent of I but maximally
mixed that was important in getting this
getting this property ok so the I guess
these things are also in one-to-one
correspondence with what are called
absolutely maximally entangled states
which are which are states where any
subsystem is maximally mixed so if you
have one of those then that's equivalent
to having one of these and from that you
can also produce a quantum secret
sharing scheme ok anyway so actually the
10 so i'm going to use today though is
not going to be this one it's going to
be this one it's going to be based on
the five cubic code so the five cubic
code gives you a six index the encoding
tensor for the five cubic code is a six
index tensor where each index runs from
1 to 0 to 1 ok so it's cubits ok so
these are just the tensors that I like
and that's a very specific one now
perfect tensors they have this nice
property that yeah relation that you
know when have you have any cubed cool
and bullying you know and you can take
the inner product between the welcome
yeah so good so so it goes one way so
anytime you have a perfect tensor you
can make a beautiful quantum error
correcting code it doesn't always go the
other way you need because remember um
so it were only one by partition or for
the can I is there any yeah so what you
more precisely you need what's called
these these threshold secret sharing
schemes which are special cases of
erasure correcting codes the thing you
need is that there aren't collections of
qubits with partial information about
this date if you that's the thing that
can get you into trouble so so in well
because I guess because with with the
secret sharing scheme right you want any
group of people collection of the shares
to either have no information or all the
information I mean I guess that's the
definition for you Oh
well I'm I i I'd have to stare at it
again but I mean I because I think this
thing about right you you really want
maximal entanglement like to get it to
be unitary like unitary is a very strong
thing right you want u dagger you to be
one and so roughly u dagger u
corresponds to if you take one of these
tensors and you write down u dagger u
equals one and then you move one of the
inputs you know you know if you take one
of these tensors and you move one of the
inputs to the outputs to get an isometry
that and then and then you contract them
right then you'll get you'll still get
an identity once o so like say i take
the 61 but then i interpret us in the
isometry from two to four okay now
that's an isometry from the 2 to the 4
so if I duty dagger T then I should get
a delta of the identity map on two
cubits but that's the reduced dense that
ends up being the reduced density matrix
on two of the cubits and it's saying
that it's maximally mixed and so so and
I want that to be true right like all
the way until i get to enough cubits
that I know everything right and that's
aside I think this is getting two
technicals I'm sorry yeah
uh yes it's a bad code that if you use
it in the way that I'm going to use it
it's a bad code because the lattice and
the bulk is a tree it's the beta lattice
and that's a bad code there's there
there's a tiny little eraser that
deletes the central cubed no no no fight
I mean five is not unique here is 25 was
the smallest number that worked okay all
right so now these these perfect tensors
they have this nice property that so say
I've got a perfect tensor here can you
know so by this I mean half the indices
so say so say so say this is three
indices and this is three indices and I
have some operator that I'm contracting
with this with half of the indices then
i can replace it by another operator
contracted with the other three indices
just by doing this stupid thing right so
a prime i define is T dagger OT and then
I take this and I substitute it here and
I get that so this means that any
operator contracted with any any three
of the indices I can push it through the
tensor and turn it into an operator
acting on the other three and by the
perfection i can do that from any 383
yeah yeah t is the perfect one here yeah
that's right yeah actually to write this
formula if i had i replace dagger by
inverse it would have been enough that
it was invertible but the the unitarity
is convenient for for other things which
i may or may not explain explicitly yeah
I mean although I must say that morally
I agree with Douglases comment before
that the tensor shouldn't actually be
unitary but here for me it's a matter of
convenience time just so we have time
almost there yeah almost there okay so
okay so um right soso yeah I already
said this but so these teas therefore
give I sama trees meaning and inner
product preserving linear maps from any
collection of the most half of their
legs to the remaining legs that's
another property of perfect answers all
right enough onto onto the model so now
the idea is that I'm going to take the
hyperbolic plane I'm going to tile it
with Pentagon's so that's sort of this
white and grey in the background here
well I guess the blue things right each
each Pentagon I'm going to interpret
I'm going to stick one of these six
index tensors there five of the legs I'm
going to contract with the neighbors and
then the sixth one which is indicated by
this red dot i'm going to leave free
okay and then i'll go out to some fixed
radius and then i'll shoot all the
remaining guys out and now i'm going to
interpret this as my big tensor where
it's a map from the in going red dots to
the outgoing white dots so this is going
to define a subspace of the boundary
hilbert space okay now why do I like
that well here's why so so say I've got
now so well this is how my collaborator
draws the picture this is how i draw the
picture so so sad now I've got some
operator acting on this dangling leg in
the center okay so so so by pushing it
through the whole map so you know by
pushing it through the entire map it
define some non local operator in the
boundary but but we can we can see how
that works very explicitly right so I I
can view I can view this guy you know
it's an operator that acts on this leg
and the identity on these two legs so
then I can use the pushing operation to
move it onto an operator that acts on
these three legs now I can do that again
here so I can push this one to here here
and here right this one to here here and
here right and so on can keep going and
eventually I'll construct some very non
local operator that acts directly on the
boundary qubits the physical qubits
which which acts within the code
subspace in exactly the same way that
this operator here would have acted in
the logical Hilbert space so so this is
like this Rindler reconstruction right
I'm reconstructing this operator on some
sub region of the boundary yes direction
so I understand that so this is you know
it doesn't in general I'm just it's just
because because I'm you know I'm
starting with the bulk operator and I
want to push it out I the there's not an
inherent directionality in the graph the
graph is undirected okay now
why are you pushing out on three legs
from yeah because because remember these
tensors i was using this operation so
that so so so an operand operation on
any three legs can go to any other three
so I was choosing to view this one and
these two is the inputs and I was
pushing on to these three outputs so but
as I think some of you were already
guessing though this is going to be
non-unique right because I mean I chose
to do that but I could have easily sent
it this way this way in that way instead
and then I would have come up with some
representation of the operator you know
down here right where I could have
picked these three and then I would have
come up with some representation of the
operator over here in fact yes so so
where I discussing the issue that bartek
brought up then I could send it this way
this way in that way that's correct yeah
and that in it okay one sentence in this
model you can reconstruct in the
entanglement wedge not just the causal
ways we discussed that with the experts
later now you can also see right so you
can see this non-uniqueness is exactly
what we expected from the 80s rindler
reconstruction right so so you know
right there's some wedge here where I
can make this there's also some other
wedge here where I can make it you also
see that operators that are closer to
the boundary I can reconstruct in
smaller wedges right so that's also the
same it's what we got from solving the
bulk wave equation okay now maybe I'll
just comment so these seem to be on some
level a new family of quantum error
correcting code so they're like
concatenated codes which I guess you
know our standard but they have loops
right you see so sometimes inputs get
you know contracted with other inputs
and the perfection of the tensors makes
that okay it preserves the isometry
property so each of these is undirected
so so it's a it's a new set a broader
set of codes you know it's interesting
to think maybe they're good for
something you know maybe they have a
better threshold and usual concatenated
codes he has that question
put it this way cool so what are you
guys is there a reason that the folder
of this this region is jealousy um sorry
you mean the so okay so you to ask that
question you should ask it the other way
you should say if I pick a boundary sub
region and then I ask what set of
tensors can I reconstruct is it bounded
by a geodesic I think the answer is yes
there's an algorithm given the boundary
region to generate a set of these guys
which are correctable we call it the
greedy algorithm which the physicist
sounds silly but it's a standard term in
computer scientists for in computer
science and its boundary is a geodesic
yeah okay now so maybe these are good
for something so let let me comment so
so the code I've literally described
here actually doesn't have literally
have a threshold good so a threshold is
so so say that with each boundary qubit
there's a probability P that I erase it
okay a threshold is the statement that
there is some finite order 1 probability
P such that if it's if p is less than
like let's call it P critical and if p
is less than P critical then then I can
correct for example this the central
qubit for example I can correct to like
sort of exponentially good precision so
as I make the system size bigger it gets
better and better protected in a way
that goes exponential in the system size
so so good codes usually have this
property what no that's that's typical
case that's that's the difference
between threshold and distance distance
is the worst case yeah okay so so so
this one actually doesn't have a
threshold there's an order one number of
erasers that kills the center but we
made do there are simple generalizations
that do they're less they're less sort
they illustrate the sort of a DSC of T
aspects of things just as well but are a
little more complicated so I explain
this one instead but actually indeed if
you do want to protect only a single
qubit
you can it seems that you can get the
threshold all the way up to a half which
is the theoretical that those sort of
theoretical upper bound on how big it
can be okay now last slide Oh second to
last slide so you might ask what
happened to the rest of the Hilbert
space so here I'm constructing just this
tiny cupboard space so well I quoted the
result before the dimensionality of this
is is 2 to the likewise re the is 2 to
the 1 over square root of five times the
total number of boundary qubits so
that's a very small fraction of the
boundary Hilbert space whereas I claimed
in the beginning that in a DSC ft every
state in the cft needs to have a bulk
interpretation so clearly we're going to
have to account for the rest of the
states somehow my claim is that I can
account for them as black holes the way
I make a black hole as I remove tensors
so say I removed the central tensor well
before there was one there was one
dangling leg there but after i remove it
now they're five because they're all
five of these and so now the subspace
has gotten bigger by doing that and you
know a little bit of it were the ones
that I would have already had any way
but I'd take the orthogonal complement
and I interpret that as a black hole of
whose size is 180s radius I can make the
black hole bigger by removing the next
layer of tensors and so that clearly as
I do that the entropy the hilt the
dimensionality the log of the
dimensionality will grow like the area
of the boundary of the region where I
remove the tensors and if I keep going
and I get all the way out to the
boundary then I've removed all the
tensors and I'm back to the identity map
which means I've accounted for the
entire Hilbert space this way and at any
finite size of the black hole it's clear
i can still describe all the operators
outside just fine by doing the pushing
outside of the outside of the horizon
out to the boundary okay now really the
last slide I promise does that mean
there are firewalls I guess someone
should talk about this see I've said
that I've removed the interior of the
black hole unfortunately not necessarily
because I've sort of this whole thing
I'm sort of only working on the 80s
scaled sized regions and you know these
big ideas black holes have this funny
property that if you jump into them you
died in an 80s time no matter
how big the black hole is which means
that whether or not there's an interior
in these models would require me to
first understand how to understand
sebelius physics which is a thing that I
don't really know how to think about in
these models in fact it's one of a
number of things that I don't know how
to think about in these models so maybe
I'll just list them in case people want
to discuss them and I'll stop so no
boundary translation invariance that
central tensor has five legs so I've
broken the continuous rotation symmetry
at the boundary to z 5v five is not a
very large group so there's you know
there's no sense in which there's you
know approximate translation and
variants accepted a very crude level
there's no dynamics I didn't tell you
what the Hamiltonian is now I told you a
little bit about the Hamiltonian because
I told you what the set of low energy
states was but that's a sort of crude
thing to tell you about the Hamiltonian
it would be nice to know more there's no
bulk diffeomorphism invariance I
mentioned that at the beginning or
earlier earlier today well I already
said this there's no sub V dias scale
locality nonetheless I think you know
these models are nice they're very
concrete they illustrate sort of the
error-correcting properties of a do cft
that we sort of convinced ourselves that
it should have i will be nice to see if
we could include some of these features
you know I mean obviously so presumably
the cft itself defines an
error-correcting code which does have
all of these features you know and
eventually if we want all of them were
probably just going to have to go to
that but you know maybe we can learn
more by sort of inching our way in that
direction ok now I'm done thanks
so I mean I'm wondering whether you want
to study interio black hole then then
you may leave I have a sub linear scale
but they also require in the dynamic
what dynamic yeah it might in mind yeah
yeah no yeah I think I mean the sibelius
locality is a subset of the things you
would need to understand so another
question also related to the Soviet EDS
thing is we go back to this formula of
Tommy Tonetta their pop field as a
functional boundary location a little
bit yeah yeah so good so in this formula
in this formula there's no problem with
sub 80s locality so sub 80s locality is
taken care of here the competition
relation cover what so I can have like
different facts all commuting with each
other a different look at this rate all
of eternity in the ball yeah which seems
to indicate about yeah but you only get
that commutation working within a
subspace of states so they only checked
the commutator 'he's in the sets of
states where you act on the vacuum with
some order one number of bulk fields and
i would claim it won't work I mean what
I mean what did usually when I give this
talk I make a lot of hay about the
algebra of bulk fields and how it can't
be realized in the cft I chose not to do
it this time but yes the anything you
think about like space like commutator
Xin the bulk is going to have to break
at the love of the operator equations
work
in the foot of the code this is
something like this do not you know you
see it because what happens is the
operators end up behind the black hole
horizon before their algebra is going to
break so so so as long as they're still
outside the black hole the algebra works
which is that which is how we said
things should work in our first paper
but I mean model you can see it very
explicitly um so if you have the code
where all the red dots or large cool
cubits yeah yeah very bad distance
because the ones right you really have
exactly that's correct so um ok so now
let's convert it to a subsystem code
good where we just include say these
ones don't care what happens to them
yeah that's right it is right and what
happens to the distance then um so it
goes up so we studied that by using the
threshold because distance was somehow
we couldn't figure out how to compute
the distance but with so with the
threshold so that's what I yeah that's
what I was going to comment on so so in
this code it's actually still bad
because it's not totally obvious but in
fact so so you see like these two points
right here so you see you see this thing
here there's like these two lines that
go this way if if I screw up these two
points and and these two if I just use
these two points and these two points I
lost here these two I can actually make
a logical operator on the central cubed
and it's only four points so the
distance is still order one but so in
the paper that's why we introduced a
generalization of this where layer by
layer you alternate between Pentagon's
and hexagons where the hexagons don't
have any dangling legs so you introduce
a less symmetric tiling with 5656 going
out and then that one has a has a has a
threshold which is order 1 like so you
know you know if you erase like I think
forget it's like you know less than
twenty percent or something you're in
good shape and if you want to go and
then the furthest you can go in that
direction is you you take only the
center one to be a pentagon and you take
the rest to be hexagons so now it's a
map just from one of these to all of the
boundary line
eggs and then for that one the threshold
seems to be a half so you so you can
realize the I think that's going to
answer my next question so if instead of
considering these outer red dots to be
gauge qubits you fix their values yes
what they are that's right that's kind
of like this that's kind of like this
it's not quite as good because then they
stop being perfect tensors so so that's
why it's we did it the other way yeah
yeah so but I mean I think yeah if you
were trying to do build a quantum
computer along these lines probably the
thing you'd want to do is do the one
where you have a central Pentagon and
everybody else is a hexagon sorry Vivian
oh so sorry if I put it about the
outside the box Cuba's you know dear
Aquabats say then the resulting state
you get that this satisfy the RT phone
almost almost yeah maybe I should
comment on that actually so so so if you
take if you take the version where
everybody has a hexagon so you just take
a hexagon tiling and you contract all
the embassies now you've given up the
subspace so it's not useful to think of
it as a code but just one state so we
call that a holographic state that one
obeys Rita kannagi exactly for connected
boundary regions so it saturates the
bound in the disconnected regions that
can't work exactly and the reason is
because there's correlation so as you
know right when Rita Kannagi is
corrected lead you know exactly you know
the leader leading order piece then the
mutual information is 0 between
sufficiently separated regions right so
in the bulk that's fixed because there's
a one of her end correction but if we
were asking it to be exact then it would
mean that there couldn't be any
correlation say between like something
here and something there and that's
wrong right i mean they're low you have
correlations yeah yeah then was a single
pentagon and all the types of guns i
should just
making a flood coat no no no it still
grows exponentially because because it
has to do with how you contract the
hexagons yeah yeah you you still arrange
it so it's more it's growing very fast
faster actually that's part of what
makes it better yeah so so if i were to
think about just this instead of being i
don't understand anything about AD
radius you here correspond well if you
didn't know anything about a toc ft um
well probably just you wouldn't have
come up with these codes i guess i mean
once we come up with them we can just
study them like any other codes yeah i
mean maybe if you were smart enough you
would have come up with him a bit for us
it was it was thinking about adrc ft
okay well how much of that picture is
this is is captured here and what's
what's missing oh you mean to get the
full a DSC ft year so that kind of has
to do with this list that i gave oh i
see so you're asked you're asking if i'm
a lazy computer scientist and I don't
want to learn about cft and if I if I
learn about this code then can I just
that can I view that as understanding a
DSC ft okay good i gotcha yeah so then
we have to go back to this list here
right so so indeed I think probably the
the two things which annoy me most from
the point of view of trying to use this
as a model of a DSC ft are that this
this thing with the sub 80s locality so
I've sort of mutilated the geometry so
it sort of its local only on scales that
are large compared to the radius of
curvature whereas in the real a DSC ft
you know we should be able to like build
the LHC or something you know I mean the
cosmological constant could be you know
the size of the universe and you know we
should be able to do local particle
physics and that should work but here
I've just sort of lumped that all into a
single tensor with where I've given
known for has no internal structure
really so so that annoys me so if you
like there's no hierarchy between the
Planck scale in the 80s scale you know
the
so that's one annoyance actually for me
personally this this this no bulk
diffeomorphism and variance is actually
the other thing that's really annoying
so in it so for example you would think
that well here's a confusing fact so any
operator in the center of the bulk here
is going to commute with local operators
at the boundary and the code subspace
but you would think that if I just act
with an operator that creates a baseball
or something in the center of the bulk
it should increase the energy of the
state you know because now there's a
baseball so it's an excitation over the
ground state but how can that how can
that happen because the Hamiltonian is
the integral de stress tensor around the
boundary which is a local operator and
so in order for a local operator in the
middle of the bulk to raise the energy
it must not really commute with all the
local operators of the boundary there
must be some if you like gravitational
Wilson line or something going off to
infinity that clicks when you act with
this operator and so that is part of the
machinery of a DSC ft but it's just lost
in this discussion here so so isn't that
saying we infer John coming to you to
the closed subspace no it's not
completely beyond the boundary it has a
component involved um yeah but that's
not true in a DSC ft I mean that in an
idiocy ft the Hamiltonian is a boundary
integral so so so so and that is a
consequence of different morphism
invariance which is just sort of not
very clear here at all you know so it's
something that some feature of gravity
you know being a the additional morphism
invariant theory that I would I would
like it if I could somehow put it into
to this model made me feel happier but
but nonetheless i mean i think zeroth
order maybe you can do what i said you
you're allowed to think that what was
the other side of this you know
about what became clear about ABS eft
now that you have this did anything um
well I think it so you know that there's
this whole religion about you know
geometry emerging from entanglement and
so on and so forth I think this is by
far the most controlled you know
illustration of that you know where you
really understand everything I think
also there's this debate that Bartek
alluded to about the causal versus the
entanglement wedge which I don't really
want to get into but this these sort of
ideas are I think strongly favored the
entanglement which I don't know I think
also just understanding better the sort
of the interplay between right i mean
the beautiful one beautiful thing about
quantum error correction is there's this
interplay between having a preferred
tensor factorization of the hilbert
space and having a subspace and when
those two sort of don't play well
together then it's actually very
interesting toso to see that that sort
of interplay is going on in a DSC FB i
think is helpful for for understanding
how is this bulk really emerging um so
in some sense you do have a Hamiltonian
for the boundary it's just very
non-local right because you have a
stabilizer code and you can write down
the generators should we interpret part
of the message of a DSC ft that there
should actually be a leg of a
low-density parity-check code with local
operators acting on the boundary that
will give they will have generated code
no no I actually so yeah so this is part
of a fight that I was having with Joe
polchinski for a long time I don't think
you should think of this as being a
low-density parity-check code I mean it
has to do with the question I asked
Daniel right because this is a one
dimensional this is a one dimensional
model so if I tried to make it with
local really local stabilizers you know
a stabilizer group that was generated by
local operators it wouldn't work like I
wouldn't be able to get the kind of
thing that I'm having here yeah but I
was asking because we know a DSC ft
actually works right if we discretized
all of that would that actually be some
kind of local low-density parity-check
code with similar
error correcting properties you're
thinking about it in the code in a
different way than what i was saying
here i mean here here it's clearly not a
low-density right but in the cft it's a
local Hamiltonian no but no but it's the
gap yeah but the but it's the integral
of a local operator it's not it's not
you don't get to say that you don't get
to impose the stress tensor separately
everywhere is it constraint it's only
the integral that in that right and
that's very important I mean that's why
that's why you can have long-range
entanglement that's I mean that's only
relevant if it's frustrated it means the
terms do not commute with each other in
a circle oh it cannot be simultaneous a
sum of local charity it's like it's all
the time out frustrated what who where
are you i'm frustrated if you have a
bunch of local constraints and
hamiltonian is a summer people you have
a ground state that satisfies all of
them that's frustration free okay now if
the ground state can't satisfy all these
constraints that's frustrated because
some of them get and and so this this
yes I don't think the ground state of a
quantum field theory is not annihilated
by acting with the stress tensor at a
point okay true statement presentation
was produces the entitlement indica
necessarily I mean I mean if you look at
if you look at actually basically any
fun of our correction code they're very
entangled that's not I mean that's not
good enough so Steve we this is a
absolute about their uprooted or a csr
use purchase cannot be a ground size of
committing
demographic yeah I think that's pretty
clear because it wouldn't have it has
too much long-range entanglement right
so actually I mean we give actually so
in that we get we actually gave a proof
and so in our paper we gave a proof that
in the context of stabilizer codes
unfortunately which I'm going to use the
term again that that this fact that you
can reconstruct stuff on disconnected
regions is impossible if the stabilizers
are locally generated that's easy to
prove
so I was somewhat naive question with
that picture in way which is I
understood correctly the the whole roll
of that network was to push out a local
operation on a single cubed and show
that it sort of axon many acts on a spit
many parts of the space area so I don't
really see this cuz the tenth circle
tensor seemed rather heavy for that's
the property oh you mean the perfect
Yeah Yeah right so that was the comment
that I made that this dis pushing really
only requires the tensors to be
invertible not not to be perfect but the
thing which requires them to be perfect
is if you want the entire tensor network
to be an isometry from the ingoing bulk
legs to the outgoing boundary legs just
from it it's just convenient now I mean
III mean so this was a comment Douglas
was making earlier today I don't think
it's necessary it just makes for a
simpler model you know it makes for
something where you can write everything
on a t-shirt look but you could you
could easily not have them BBB you know
you could what you would do if they were
just invertible is you would you would
push all the states through and then you
would just take their linear span and
call that the code subspace I think it I
think it would be fine if you want I
mean if you want the dangling legs to
represent some sort of physical degrees
of freedom that's right yeah you want
you want that i want the isometry that's
right so we wanted to have a simple I
mean we wanted this picture that a local
bulk operator here is really just an
operator on this dangling leg in that I
wanted the operator here to commute with
the operator there and I wanted that to
be preserved pushing it through the map
ok so